they knew they might die at sea but
these migrants took the risk leaving
from Tunisia on a dangerous voyage
across the Mediterranean that this year
alone has claimed more than a thousand
lives arriving hours later on Lamba
deucey a tiny Italian island closer to
Tunisia in Italy this is the fourth
group of migrants to have arrived here
in the past 17 hours or so now all the
migrants that I've spoken with here in
Lampedusa they've been too afraid to be
interviewed on camera most of them are
traumatized by what they described as a
harrowing journey across the
Mediterranean and they're also terrified
about the uncertainty they now face days
earlier a far sadder scene when a boat
carrying approximately 50 migrants
capsized off the island of Lampedusa 22
people were rescued but at least 13
migrants all women died others are
missing ambulance driver Giacomo Matina
helped transport bodies pulled from the
water we people from les buhdeuce always
help we always will don't like it when
you say per se that we don't want them
here but it's not just newspapers
expressing those sentiments
Carmelo Maggiore who owns a boat rental
business says she used to support those
arriving here but she says that changed
when migrants stole one of her boats
nowadays even if one of those women come
here
I'm not going to welcome her because
they cause me harm I know that not all
are the same but after a while you
become harsher and you can't do what you
would do before known as the Gateway to
Europe Lampe dosa is increasingly at the
forefront of an intense debate in Italy
on whether migrants should be welcomed
or turned away the hard line closed
ports policy of former interior minister
Matteo salvini has at least for now been
replaced by a more humane approach to
migration under Prime Minister Giuseppe
Conte center-left coalition government
Italy is working with Germany France and
Malta to establish a quota system for
distributing migrants
rescued at sea so far they've been
unable to get potential partner
countries to agree the identities of
most of the migrants buried in Lampa
doose's cemetery are unknown aid worker
Alberto Maillard o believes it's
important for him to be among the first
Europeans to welcome people who've
suffered so much he blames Italy's
politicians for polarizing opinion
unfortunately a lump reducer is an
Italian island which is influenced by
the overall public debate and right now
many people even if they face directly
the death of people at sea the sentiment
would say he's quite sane of all being
on other parts of the island sit other
types of graveyards the remains of
vessels that were meant to deliver so
many desperate people to safety
a stark reminder a futures envisioned
but never realized
hamaji I'm Jim al Jazeera wampa dusit
Italy